إذا كنت تحب الآيس كريم ولكن لا يمكنك الحصول على
أخبار جيدة عن منتجات الألبان
، فلديك الكثير من الخيارات هذه الأيام ،
أصبحت الحلويات المجمدة المصنوعة من
فول الصويا والكاجو وحليب جوز الهند
سائدة ويمكن أن تتذوق طعمها مثل الشيء الحقيقي
إذا كنت تراقب وزنك أو
قلقًا بشأن صحة القلب ، يمكنك
العثور على خيارات تناسب ميزانياتك اليومية من
السعرات الحرارية والدهون ،
على سبيل المثال ، تحتوي حلوى حليب الصويا هذه على
120 سعرة حرارية فقط وصفر جرام من
الدهون المشبعة لكل وجبة ،
ولكن لا يتم إنشاء جميع الأطعمة غير المصنوعة من منتجات الألبان على
قدم المساواة وقد لا تكون كذلك  أي نوع صحي أكثر
من الإصدار التقليدي ،
تناول الحلويات التي تحتوي على حليب جوز الهند
بشكل عام ، فهي تحتوي على نسبة أعلى
من الدهون المشبعة
التي ترفع نسبة الكوليسترول السيئ ، لذا
انتبه إلى
الملصقات التي تحتوي على أقل من 200
سعر حراري ، و 16 جرامًا من السكر
و 3 جرامًا من الدهون المشبعة لكل وجبة
و  راقب أحجام الأجزاء التي
عادة ما
تكون نصف كوب فقط أو حوالي حجم
المصباح الكهربائي